so you posted a video that went
so viral oh my god
when did you see it how did you see it
how did you
where how origin you must follow
tank's good news right yes in fact he's
been on the show
we love him love him love
he posted it and i just saw it and i
just felt like
she captured exactly although she's had
a huge loss this year but
she just captured the overall feeling of
like what in the world has this year
been
you know but but it doesn't erase your
joy what a joy to see her
having suffered a loss and having had
such a rough year and still just
being like ugh what are you gonna do i
just i might
i applauded her resilience i guess
this woman's name is robin shaw and this
video of her went extremely viral to say
the least
and it is of her looking at and
discovering her goal
list that she wrote for herself for
2020.
take a look okay
tell me if this is not hilarious all
right go one
make more money i would you know been
unemployed since march
travel more lose weight
be more social
i wrote cry less cry less cry less i've
got every single day of this whole
fantastic
um spend more time
how funny i ever
if that wasn't enough um you posted it
on your wall
and then this happened i have another
quick video check this out
i literally died i died and i know my
neighbors can hear me so don't call
cause 911 right there jennifer
garner posted her video
on her wall
[Applause]
well when that video went up it got a
million
plus views and so
um we wanted to give robin like
sort of a surprise and she doesn't know
that you're here and she's going to
freak out is that okay
yes are you kidding me i can't wait okay
we have to mute you to pull off the
surprise
okay shh please welcome
robin shaw
my goodness i am so excited to meet you
everybody is freaking out i mean chelsea
handler khloe kardashian oprah
oh i know i know and i know
that this all really started because of
one jennifer garner all right the whole
thing is absolutely crazy but
in the 15 seconds it took her to
upload that video all the years of
working so hard my entire life just
changed like that
it just the whole thing is just crazy
but she really just
started the whole thing
well i'm gonna uh do something you in
three seconds ready i'd like you to meet
someone
one two three
[Applause]
oh my god jen i would have cleaned if i
knew you were coming
oh my goodness
hi wait this is the greatest girl hang
ever everyone's gonna be so jealous
oh where's the wine
oh my god i have i have like oh god i'm
not even wearing shoes guys
i'm not okay i'm not okay
oh my goodness you don't need pants in
2020
i think we all discovered that it's
under my chair but i'm not i was like
why am i wearing heels
but hi ladies hi robin
um jen you don't even know oh my god
don't make me cry
oh my god dad when you upload that video
you don't know it changed
everything that one post set everything
up
i worked so hard thank you so much
oh my gosh i promise i'm a comedian but
i'm also emotional yeah
i'm still a girl why you're so funny
because you're
you you just let us see into you
the most important thing you can be is
you with your hair in a bun
and you know like fingernails all over
the place
and having a glass and a cry and a laugh
and and thank you thanks for
inviting us in oh i think it's just so
everyone was so
alone this year and i'm just so
glad that i was able to just post
something that made people feel less
alone
i think i really think that's the best
thing to come from all of this
you